well 2020 strikes again with more star
splits
sheryl hines is here in the house star
of i can see your voice and of course
robert f kennedy
junior's better half cheryl this year
really has tested romances oh it has
everybody's stuck together yeah and then
they're stuck together and split apart
like julianne huff and brooks like
nothing apparently could save their
marriage
i've been on my own we're kind of doing
our separate things right now
i cry all the time and it's wonderful
julianne filed for divorce
monday the move comes five months after
she and brooks announced their
separation
a source tells e.t julianne and the
former nhl pro quote
finally came to the realization that
they aren't meant to be together
after attempting to reconcile in
september we're told
julianne feels like she hasn't had a
chance to live her life to the fullest
and brooks well he's getting in tune
with his emotions
and talked about it on his podcast how
men think
i've learned how to honor emotions in
the moment
and let them come up and through me and
a lot of times that's through crying
now to another split real housewife of
beverly hills erica jane
is divorcing her husband of 21 years
attorney tom girardi
erica who filed yesterday says this is
not a step taken lightly or
easily girardi has a net worth of around
30 million dollars
so is there a prenup i don't have a
prenup
let me be very clear i'm married to a
very powerful lawyer
a prenup wouldn't stand in his way
anyway so it doesn't matter whether you
had one or you didn't
it's going to be all tom's way i assure
you also filing divorce papers
hgtv's christina anstead she and her
husband ant separated in september
the pair have a one-year-old son and
were married less than two years
and the life changes just keep coming
for ann we've learned
he'll no longer host his car show
wheeler dealers
the series is moving back to the uk and
he's being replaced
also tonight news on a bachelor star's
restraining order
i put a lot of pressure on our
relationship colton underwood who
allegedly put a tracking device on his
ex cassie randall's car tells e.t he
reached a private agreement with her
and says she's asked the court to
dismiss her restraining order against
[Music]
him
you